大家晚上好啊
声音视频正常的话打个E好吗
OK
我也是刚回来啊
出去待了几天
今天晚上呢我跟大家讲一下这个策略的问题
问题
就是没有什么行情的分析
也没有什么策略
因为我现在都在持仓过程当中
好吧
所以没有没有这个策略的方面
策略方面的话你们可以问一下
其他两个老师
我今天只是教学部分
OK
然后呢
多和空
你不要来问我
啊
长还是跌
盘面上自己会告诉我们
好吧
看下时间啊
今天可能讲的稍微快一点
因为明天要那个了
要回到工作岗位了啊
所以晚上呢
跟大家讲一下策略的问题
我们以黄金为例啊
今天呢
我跟大家分享的东西呢
叫这个
同歧恩通道
也就是同歧恩通道
如果大家知道的话
可以在屏幕上打个6
当前通道
好吧
那么今天呢
这个策略是非常简单的
我讲完可能只要五分钟
那么我是这个意思啊
我讲完的
讲完以后呢
你们要花时间去复盘
OK
就是说你把你能你能找到所有的这个K线图全部找出来
然后呢
再把我今天跟你讲的所有符合这个特征的用我这个方法然后你们去复盘这是功课清楚了没有策略是非常简单的
但是呢你们要花很多时间去复盘
这个东西
我说实话
不能量化的
不能量化
就是说你非要给他定一个定数
那没有
OK
好
那么这个方法呢
经过这个海上的我们的回撤试了一下
我今天讲的这个方法使用在黄金上
效果是最好的
当然其他品种也还差不多
但是黄金的效果会比较好一点
唐吉安的通道的参数是21
也就是一个月的交易
天数
去掉这个星期六星期天
大概平均算的话
一年一个月的话是21个交易日左右
OK
还要去掉一些节假日什么的
好吧
就是它设定是非常简单的
那么航天通道呢
它有两根线
一个是上轨
一个是下轨
我建议的各位是上轨
你不用看
你看的是下轨
以上步骤能听清楚的
屏幕上回复一个8
首先你需要有一个唐签通道
然后它的参数是21
然后上面那个不用看
我们只看下线
就唐签通道的下轨
黄金上面
好吧
那么近20年以来的回撤数据呢
就记住20年以来的啊
从2000年到现在
应该是对
20年的回撤数据来看
用我们这个策略
当然你能找到这些的数据也可以
找到1970年到现在也可以
50年也可以
一般普遍目前的行情软件上
所能提供的数据
大概就到1975年了
再往前就没有了
就很难找到了
再往前你就在软件上是找不到
但是在那些数据库里是有的
但是它不成这个不连续好吗我们只讲今天的策略好回来看房间通道的它的原理非常简单就是21天的
过去21天的最高点
和过去21天的最低点
能明白吧
过去的最高和最低
那么我们这边讲一下
这个数学理论
它里面有个数
你们要记住
就是1
就是π
π的根号的
然后分之1
大概是0.几左右
0.4到0.5
这个数字你们要注意
那么
具体的得出的结果
大概是0.4到0.5的
一个值
π的话就是3.1415927
好吧
是一个正态分布
这个你们不用去了解
它的背后的这个数学逻辑
你只要记住这个参数就可以了
0.4到0.5
好
那么
21的乘以0.4或者0.5
然后你要把这个数字记住
那么其实这个数字是固定的
固定的
大家可以一起算一下
21乘以0.4
还有21乘以0.5
大概等一几
8到10之间
能理解吧
就是说你把这个正态分布值
0.4到0.5
那么通过这个天数嘛
21天嘛对吧
然后反推得出的是8到10
这个8到10是干什么用的
待会我会跟你们说
就是说
他跌破过去21天的价格往下
比60%以上的时间是落在8天到10天的
这个不理解的话
我给你们画一个图
好
那是60%
这里是20%
这里是20%也就是说它的这个震态分布的峰值出现在是哪个个区域出现在60这个范围里面然后这逐步升高然后逐步降低
懂了吗
有时候会超出去
它会超出去
超出去的部分是占40%
但是呢
我们说了极限
两个极限的话是各在20%
就有时候你会看到它跌破21的吧
然后跌了一个月
或者跌了两个月
或者连跌三个月
这种概率是小概率事件
能听懂的打个6
什么意思啊
比如说这个位置破了这个21天
对吧
我们看这里这个位置
它一般往下走8到10天
一般就会有反弹
这是数学
这个数学正态分布来的
当然背后的数学逻辑比较复杂
你们不用管
你们只要知道这个数字就可以了
也就是说
它跌破21
它大概
大概率走的这个最长时间就是8到10
那么有时候会抽出去的
抽出去的这一部分
我们就管它叫肥伪效应
就统计学上讲的这个
越不可能发生的事情越发生的
就那个20%的几率就要来
明白了吧
它大概就跌到这
再往下跌个8到10天
它一定会有反弹出来的
这个概率是60%以上
能明白的打个6
能听懂吗
到这一步能听懂吗
OK
那么这里稍微牵扯到一些量化的问题
但是大家注意不要去过度拟合
就是说你不要去非去找8到10天
那你说他走不到这个时间
你看这边下来之后走了6天就可以
那么黄金这个品种一般是走6到7
之前我跟大家说
我就连续你看到6根阴线以上的这个行情
它超跌反弹就要来
懂了吗
但是我们说通过数学的范围
它是落点在什么位置最多
8到10
就差不多到一个
大概率的极限位置了
但是我们不排除
有时候它会跌峰了
比如说15年的时候
13年
这一波看到了吗
那你看
这个点跌破了对吧
你数一下123456789
好了翻弹了对吧
这个地方其实你看
它破位的时候是
在哪里这个地方破的
这个位置的吧
一二两天就跌完了
这就是我前面画的正台风波的那个旁边那部分
就大部分时间是落在这里嘛
这里有20%
这里20%
这个20%是什么意思
就是超过8到10天
这里的20%就是他用很短的时间就
跌去很多
有这种情况就是速度非常快
但是时间非常短
在这个A区
这个是速度不一定很快
时间特别长
这叫B区
大部分时间在C区
也就是8到10天
这里是没办法量化的
但是你只要知道一件事情
就是这个地方速度是
时间是很短的
速度是很快的
懂了不
但无法用时间去衡量
你像这两天就跌完了
那两天跌去大概200点左右
对吧
200美金
这种就是超出我们正常的这种
统计范畴的
所以小概率事件
你不能说我做交易
我就指望这种行情
天天我就等待这种行情
那你抓不到
你大概率的是抓这个行情的
懂了吗
OK
那给大家做下一步的
那么把原理搞明白了之后
那么你要去想一个问题
对吧
价格为什么会跌破21亿
这个问题
你要去想啊
对吧
我们来说一下这个问题啊
一个价格涨涨涨
好
它的21代这个位置
假设啊
这个位置
好
现在跌破
那么跌破了这个意味着什么呢
它把过去21天的这个楼给打掉了
对吧
那么换句用最简单的逻辑去讲这个
讲这个事情就是表示
21天前所有的买盘
现在都是浮亏的
这点能不能懂
就是你倒退21天以前
最低点以上所有的这个K线
或者说不管它什么K线
这个价位以上的
是不是在这一天都已经被什么
打成浮亏状态了
如果还没跑的话
好
那么一个月了
对不对
一个月之前的价格已经被干掉了对吧那么好那么不是我说看到什么看到它粘着这个21在这边就是21不断的在刷新低点
对吗
打下去打下去
那么我跟你们说清楚
打下去意味着什么
因为这抛了
开始什么
割肉了
顶不住了
那你就记住啊
这个动作出来就表示顶不住了
你看砍仓
砍仓
懂了吗
这就是砍仓的信号
你只要理解这个意思就可以
就是说之前的那个做多的走了
顶不住了
理解了没有
其实两方面
一方面是前面多头跑了
然后呢新增的空头进场了
懂了吗
就刚刚跟进去
就跟市的那帮人进去了
顺市的这帮人
就他去做空
对吧
这边是多头止损
多头止损
空头跟进空头跟进空头跟进
好再回到原来前面第一步
那么一般我们可以看一下啊
他杀破新低以后
他会有什么动作
那正常的情况他会回踩对吧
反弹对吧
好看到了啊
你看这连续有四个低点吧
这里一个这里一个
这里一个这里一个对吧
后面就是连续的六根
六根连续的这个K线下去的啊
然后每一次过后
它会有超跌反弹
超跌反弹
为什么会出现这个现象
因为多头跑了
它的这个抛压就减轻了
懂了吗
还有一种情况是摊毛盘
什么叫摊毛盘呢
就是说空头手上没有这个
也不是摊毛盘啊
就是空头手上的筹码不够了
怎么办
不货
懂了没有
他需要拿点子弹继续往下炸
手上没有空单了
所以他不货
有可能就会采用什么锁仓
然后上去再开空的方法
对吧
积累空单
然后往下去炸就行了
懂了没有
操盘上面就是这个意义
但是我们现在讲
我们是直接落地要实践的
所以现在我教你们方法
认真听
只讲一次
当然应该是可以上传到这个视频上的
而且我可以保证你们以前从来没有听过也没有人去公开过这个好不好没反应呢
都没反应吗
不想学呗
你们肯定就是说你最好给我个单子啊
让我能赚钱就行了
对吧
我不想学
好
开始
这个点标记一下
看到了吧
破了
我们所有破的这些地点都标出来
就是破掉这个21点新低的这个价格
全都拉出来
拉出来之后
看好这个线
就是跌破21的那根线
我们把它定为基准线
也就是base
k
我写一下
看看能不能加上去
它触发
就破了21的价格的K线
就是BaseK
能看到了
我们把标出来
那么这几根都是
跌破的都算
这里
懂了吧
这几个
还有这边也是这边也是这边也是
好
那么现在你只要干一件事情
基准线找到了对吧
找到了没有
基准线找到以后
你需要用
你只要需要一把指尺就够了
我们的主持也说过一句话
各位把指尺我便可祖恒天下
在理查的
丽莎贝克先生讲的
OK
等一下
我把它这边都标给你们看一下
当然你们可以在软件上面自己标出来
懂吗
你不一定就是说
你都可以把它标出来
这些地方
就击穿过的都可以标出来
懂了吧
好
那我先就标最近的
好吧
这几个标完之后
这几个点是一个比一个低的
对吧
你不用管它
好
现在你要干的事情就是
基准点找到了以后往左边往左开始画向阳趋势线能不能理解比如说我给大家画一下
从左边开始画
线段
我这边放大一下
找到基准线的高点
看我这样
会画了吧
这里还有一次对吧
这里还有一次
我在天图上给大家画出来的啊
如果看不清楚
我再用这个粗一点的线
给你们去讲这个事
高点在这对吧
连啊高点
基准K的高点连线
它跟基准K的这根高点连线
这
还有这里一个
这里有一个破位对不对
这里还有一次对吧
然后你看后面会发生什么事情
它出现了这个动作以后
它出来了
出来了就要反弹
这不是什么神奇的东西
非常简单
一学的东西
我给你们画一下
你看
出来了吧
反弹了两天
再打一个
这会反弹厉害了
对吧
反弹
这边有没有这一天上来的
对吧
反弹
这边有没有反弹
这边有吧
这一天反弹了一天
然后我们又来了
这波反弹比较猛
看出来了吧
好我们再往前看
这一波有吧
这一波
这一波啊
这个这根K线跌破的对吧
然后这里又来了对吧
那这根线又破了对吧
好你画线
那当然最后一个是这么画的对吧
那
等一下啊
这个高点到这个
这根破线的K线的这个
Base K的最高点连线
这里你也可以画上去
懂了吧
因为这一根线是在这儿了嘛
这也可以画
那么好
这边反弹开始
所以说这个系统是什么
是反转系统
它不是顺势系统
它是反转系统
那么反转系统有一个优势是什么
大家知不知道
它胜率很高的
懂了
就是说你出来之后至于能长多远
你不用去管它
就哪怕谈一天
他也是要谈的
那么运气好的话多谈几天
这种策略的做法是非常简单的
我跟你们说怎么去做
那么当你发现
基准线和前期高点的高点的这个连线被突破了以后
你盘中不是跟进去吗
你做你就抢反弹了
对吧
做多了对吧
做超跌反弹
那么好
进场以后
单子一旦有了利润
你就拉宝本
后面就不用管它了
听得懂吗
就比如你进场了之后
上去涨了
比如说黄金
涨了三美金左右
你就可以拉宝本了
打掉了完之后
不动
等下一次跌破21的时候
我再干一次
那么
只要有一次不打你宝本算
你就一直拿着
那么这一笔交易
可能会给你赚了
非常非常多的利率
不知道各位能不能听懂
比如说去年这一波行情
这一天基准线跌破了
对吧
滑线
高点连起来
看到了没有
这里是这个
Base K
Base K之前的高点
波段高点在这
对吧
那你这样画其实也可以
反正你就贴着它走
这个写下来
看到了吧
那么不出来你不用动
它不往右走的话
你不出来你不用管它
直到
然后你就等着
我们走线
动不动
不动
没动对吧
不突破对吧
因为这边又刷新掉了
看到了没有
这边又刷新了
那么这刷新的话
其实线也不用变的了
对吧
这两个点是一样的
继续等
好出来了
我重新画一下啊
出来了不收线收上来了对吧收到外面去了对吧收线收进去了好强反弹那么你是这里进的
假设第二天
这天不敢进对吧
第二天一看好
进去之后拉一个什么
先拉初始止损嘛
初始止损就可以放在这个位置
懂了没有
就是当出现
这个信号之前的那个地点
就是你的止损位置
之后就按照我说的方法
打宝本就打宝本
不打宝本我就一直拿
我就一直拿下去
听得懂没
拿到什么时候
拿到他打到21天的上位
我在做指引
就突破21天的新高
这个位置你再考虑指引
就要有这个气魄
来学会了打个六
是不是很简单
为什么我们要去试仓
为什么要这么设
你要搞明白这个原理
看似我们是做反转系统的
实质上我们是要抓趋势的拐点
但不一定每次都能拐成
因为它很可能
下一次又打掉21天
对吧
但是背后的原理你要明白
就是这个破东西
它是涨多跌少的
所以我请你们今天的这节课认真听
就当你发现黄金这个品种
跌破这个21的时候
你要兴奋起来
懂吗
就它这个东西它跌了
你要开心
因为机会都是跌出来的
包括这一次
这懂吗
机会都是跌出
还有08年的那一波
很多东西呢
我回头
我说为什么让你们复盘去看
你要懂啊
当中的原理
对吧
你看这一次
这一次跌的
对吧
那这这这啊
大师很多人说
这个地方要去500
对不对
那你看一下
这波可能你拿不住
为什么
因为你打到上轨了吗
对不对你这个位置你看啊这个位置你自己看这个地方当地方当时是那个低点对吧一波什么涨到哪个地方去了涨到1900去了
对于你能不能拿这么长时间
我不晓得
但是我给你的目标
是最少拿到21的高点
对于黄金这个品种来说
天图上是不少的
那么我们以现在为例
现在21天的价格在哪里
高点在这个位置
1755对吧
那么如果说你是在之前这个位置开进去的
那么你现在至少要拿到1755才能平仓的
懂了吗
因为你的初始止准是放在这个位置的
对不对
有人说
我前面那波什么
我进场了之后呢
他这边都给我打掉了
你保本了吧
不亏钱吗
然后呢
你就等下一次
下次再跌破的时候
就是你的机会
那么
如果说没有呢
没关系
后面会给你
比如说这没有下来
怎么办
很简单
他后面也会给你的
这个地方他会给你
懂了没有
你这里没抓到
没关系
他后面
因为他这个间隔
是这么涨上去的
因为只要价格
确实在往上的
他的21天的low
也会往上升的嘛
他总会被碰到一次给你的嘛
懂得没有
你看这一波道指
用这个方法怎么做
我不是说吗
我说去年到现在
最大的笑话就是做空道指
谁做谁死
你看去年你只要
用这个方法用的好
你看你道指能不能不赚钱吗
你就等着
你看大哥这里来了
对吧
这里跌破过一次
好机会
对吧
这里跌破过一次
还有这里跌不过一次
本来这个地方我想进的
没下去
对不对
你自己看
你应该给你掌握这个方法
你看
哦
原来这么玩呢
买了不动
不就完了
懂了没有
那么你怎么做呢
比如说你在这里买
最小指引
打到这我就跑了
为什么
突破20天新高
这一段你抓到了吧
好你这个位置进去了手指根线突破了打到21天你跑了吧这进到这这对吧这里又一次对不对首先你这里买的打到21你跑了吧
这里一次
首先突破上去
打到21天你跑了吧
所以你要记住
跌下来
你要会玩
新手怕几点
老手怕阴点
高手怕不点
得顶级高手跌了也白跌
而且现在你也知道
目前宏观上是什么一个态势
它是灌水的状态
你就往后几年
你再也看不到像现在这种行情了
什么几万亿几万亿往下砸的
那个等到下一次金融危机了
或者是什么
对吧
下一次这种全球性事件发生的时候
才会看到
理解了吗
当然今天讲到这个东西是纯技术上的
就是利用超跌
利用人性的什么
另一面
实质上你认为我们在做反转
在抓拐点
实质上我们在利用人性
那个点是没人敢买吧
懂吧
一般人不敢进的
不敢进的位置就是最好的位置
所以看似简单的逻辑背后
它当中是蕴含了很多道理在里面的
OK
然后呢
这个是手法的问题
下面就是讲时间的问题
每个品种
这个就是你需要你们自己去做海上的这个预算了
就是说
比如说黄金
我们前面说过8到10对吧
其实它很多时候到不了这个数字
这个数字是全市场我们普世性的一个数字
能不能懂
什么叫普世性
就是说黄金原油白银铜镍银天然气
全部加在一起
就是所有的品种
比如说100个平均放在一起的
它的普世的时间轴是8到10天
就是一般来说跌破这个值连续下跌
8到10天
它就会出现超跌反弹
这是大概率事件
那么你要在细化到某一个平均上面
你需要做历史数据的回撤
算出它的什么平均值
比如说10年20年30年
这个数字
我建议各位不要
不要把近一年的这个数据统计进去
你要统计的时候是不能这么统计的
跟你们说一下
2020年不要统计进
你时间的话
比如说是1999年到2019年
这一年
你也不要统计进去
两个问题
第一个你把今年统计去之后
有可能会过度拟合
第二个是因为去年是全球极端事件发生
实际上是史无前例的
所以你统计的时候这么统计
你就筛选到99年到19年
然后去每个品种你去测算
它跌破完之后
大概平均什么时间会拉回来
这就是功课
你们要做量化的话
就要研究这个东西
然后你心里这个时间你有数了
对不对
比如说我们知道黄金大概六到七天左右
那你就很清楚了
你就数着嘛
白银跟黄金都是遵循六和七的一个数字的
懂吗
就连续跌了六七天以上
他就会有个反拉动作
至于反拉多少
就不用管他
你也测不了的
懂了没有
就真的这个上升趋势来的时候
哪怕他突破
就是比如说你这个地方
你抄底抄到了
你打到这你跑了
他可能后面还是涨了
他还会找
你看后面不是又找上去了吗
对不对
就是你这跑了怎么办
跑了没关系
你得下一个点
这个点出来了吧
你在这个点卖
怕就怕什么呢
那就是说
我们现在讲这个系统最弱的地方
就是说
他最薄弱的环节在哪里
给你们看一下
他有弱点的啊
他不是说没有弱点
有弱点
弱点就是这种情况
明白来打个一
你看
就是这个震荡
对吧
有的
真来单边
他不给你机会的
你上不了车
你仔细看
他没有一次是打到这个
下线给你的没机会
现在给了对吧
现在当然给了啊
之前是没有的
那么这波你只能眼巴巴的看他往上吵
这是他的弊端
有时候他就是这样
他不去啊
价格就在这个上面
他不往不往这靠啊
所以你想进很难很难进场
那么这种时候你就用这个策略就办不到了
因为你这个地方已经逃逸出去
已经不是拐点的这个策略能够帮助你的时候了这个是你要采用的什么顺势的策略比如说突破策略你这用抓管点的策略是抓不到的他就压根不给你拐点你抓个屁啊懂了没有那么什么时候去用
就跌得最惨
就跌得大家都很恐慌的时候
这时候你用拐点系统
限制限决
这也是我为什么每次能成功的原因
今天跟大家分享这个东西
我觉得我讲的很
我已经讲的很
这个很细了
那么指引标准
你就以上限为标准就可以了
指限于做多
做空没有
今天我没有教过你们怎么做空
好吧
我今天讲的只是怎么去做多的问题
学会了吗
打个吧
以后看到夏天你要开心的
我都跟你们说了
就是说你把人类历史拉长之后去看嘛
对吧
以前五块钱的棒笔你是吃不到
不是五毛钱的棒笔你吃不到的
对不对
以前五块钱的盒饭你也吃不到了
这个通膨会一直带着这个生产资料的价格往上走
包括你现在肯定买不到五千块钱一瓶的房子了
一线城市
不可能的
懂了没有
除非发生战争
因为我跟大家说过
和平年代财富不会消失
只会膨胀
对吧
战争年代财富会消失的
退党从来炸没了
我们重新干
那是大家回到同一起抱歉
就是说
唯一能够拉近贫富差距的
只有发生战争
在战争面前
不管你是有钱人
还是穷人都一样
一颗核弹过来
对不对
一个大国魔杀上行武器过来
我不管你什么身价多少亿
没用
那哪怕你乞丐
你跟身价一百亿的
在这个面前都是一样的
财富已经不重要了
懂了没有
当然现在我们说
我们又生活在和平年代
所以它就是
总值是不会变的
只是再分配的问题
所以它是呈现出什么
楼线已经上涨了
清楚了没有
我再讲得细一点就是说你等到下一次或者说你大家今天来看一下你们复盘看一下啊
我们看一个看一个品种
等一下啊
让我想想是哪个
铜吗
等等啊
看一下铜
你看一下铜
他这个笔别有好一点的地方在哪里呢
他今年
你看他给你几次机会
本来这一次也差一点
今天直接拉回去了
我还想让他结后能够来一下吧
不给
同没有机会了
对吧
就这个品种
你仔细去看一下他的过程
你现在知道啊
他确实走出来
其实你当时拐点的时候
你是不知道的
你这个地方你是不知道的
对吧
那仔细看他
他这边走了几天
10天左右
你仔细看一下啊
你看你数一下是不是10啊
从第一次打到这个线开始算嘛
1234567890
8到10之间
就是你按照这个算
打到这个位置开始算之后
你再看这一次
跌破了对吧
12345678
翻弹
1234567899
那么好
这边还有一个技巧跟大家分享一下
就是对于这个21的low的冲击
越狠
他反弹那就越猛
能不能理解这句话
你看啊
我给你找这个啊
你看这一段和这一段的区别在哪里
时间差不多
两个都是八九天对不对
但是对于冲击力度
就对于这根黄色的这个下轨
冲击力度是哪波强
是B段
这种情况叫撕裂
撕裂模式
就是说他的那个
他就是他的21天的那个low天天创新低不是股不是价格天天创新低是21天的唐签通道的下跪而且拉扯的间距是非常大的那么记住
对这个21天下距
间距打得最凶的
它反弹也是最猛的
就是有什么样的撕扯
后面就会有什么样的反弹
听懂了打个料
我们管它叫冲击
你看
时间是一样
它的冲击力度是不一样的
就是跌的这种没有人性的时候
比这种阴跌要小跌要强
所以它的反弹也是很强的
利用这个原理
就是说你当你看到收盘价天天创新体
已经不稀奇了
对吧
你看到这个21天的这个下跪
天天打新体
那才叫凶狠的
你可以平定一下
因为21表是一个月的
那一个月的低点不停的在打心底
那你就明白了
懂了吧
这种情况呢
就是给人一种感觉就是世界毁灭掉了
然后生无可恋了
对吧
这是我借用巴菲特一句话
是吧
别人恐惧的时候
我应该准备好态了
准备好态了
怎么准备
今天就是这个方法
OK
很多人呢
把这个唐谦通道
当做这个趋势跟踪指标
对吧
或者说趋势跟踪的系统
有没有错
其实也没有错
啊
以后如果说
因为今天我就讲到
怎么去做波段
对吧
我没有跟你们说
怎么去拿
长线的单子
其实当长线单子
我一句话也讲完了
就是说
当你捕捉到这个
就是什么
机会来了之后
那么你就等到他涨上去
打上轨我不走
跌破下轨我再跑
这就是跟踪TF的方法
能不能理解
那比如说这个天我抓进去了
按道理我打到上轨我要跑了
对吧不跑
守黄线
跌破黄线我再出来
那这一波你就吃大的了
懂了
就两种平仓的思路
当然你做黄线的话
就是做趋势分钟那一段
这这段是你的利润对吧
就是按照这个标准的这个
上线出平仓的这个方法
你要是按照黄线出的话
那就平仓方法就不一样的啊
那你要
付出更多时间去换换这个利润
换这一波利润
理解了吗
哪种更好呢
根据自己情况
实际上说恕我之言
各位在权益的兄弟朋友们
可能大部分都都拿不住的
没这个实力
不是没这个
没这个
不是实力的问题啊
就是说没有这个能力
去去去去持有这种仓位
时间上啊
稍等一下
就是说对大家比较友好的方法
就是打上轨你就跑了
就21天新高创出来你就走
这是比较友好的方法
懂了没有
因为你想拿这个东西
你其实你还要对他的这个宏观基本面
还有有什么有研究
懂了吗
但是你们能把这个超级反弹做好
也就可以了
好吧
这个东西
这个就是这一段是后面进阶的时候在学的
这样今天我也说了
就你们今天只要完成这个动作就可以
只要把这个学会
拐点就破线拐头
好吧
下面提问时间
就是我前面讲的这部分内容
有什么你听不懂的地方
我再给你们解答
好吧
来打字
天土
天土啊
天土会吧
日线图
小石头的胜率和这个天图的胜率是不一样的
你要懂明白啊
因为一天有24个小石头线
23根
对吧
一个月只有二十几根天图
所以级别是不一样的啊
高点哪里定就是说他触及你看啊他第一次跌破21天的这个低点的这根线作为Base K
对吧
基准线
然后往前找他的最高点
然后连线就可以了
他触及一次你就画一下调教啊
然后呢中间画线的时候还要考虑一个时间问题
懂了没有
比如说
你之前没有注意到这个品种
但是他这边已经跌了七八天了
就是你要卡这个卡时间懂吗
一波单边往下走
大概八到十天
这时候你要准备好去划线了
找到最后一个接针点
然后找到最后一个接针点
之前的那个反弹的高点
给他一根线往下一划
这根线一般来说都很陡
大概接近于70度以上的角度
能不能理解
然后呢
记住啊
除了这个方法以外
还有一个方法
就是说它的下跌角度是大于70的
大家记住
那么它要走反弹的第二个条件
一定会满足一个条件的
跟大家说一下
它的反弹一定会大于30度
这是这个上涨
怎么给你们画这个事
给你们解释一下
这是90度对吧
这个角度是90度
大概75度左右
这个值是75
懂了吗
然后呢
这是负的75度啊
然后它回来的时候
它有30度
它会沉醒出30度上涨
就是说所有的反弹
往上走大波段的
它必须的幅度是大于30的
如果你看到这个反弹的这个速度
很弱
它是这种邪律
不算
因为这个可能连20度都没有
30度
这个怎么去亮化
你自己用眼睛看
或者拿个圆规自己瞄一下就知道了
懂了吗
角度
一个是速度
一个是角度
还有一个是幅度
其实幅度跟速度包含在一起了吗
对不对
懂了吗
就第一根线打
就是破心低
不是破心低
就是他打穿这个21天的这个对底点的时候
就是你的标就记它为基准线
基准线之前的高点
往它一个趋势线一画然后这里面包含的时间最好是大于等于八天懂了吗八天到十天这个范围概率比较大
这时候你就等一件事情
等它出来
它上涨的角度要大于三十
那么有时候有一种情况
就是它上涨的角度也很陡
就什么意思
他这个这样迫上来的时候
他不是这种角度上来的啊
比如说这一天
他不是
他是这样一根线
这种角度
就是反弹也接近70度以上的这种情况
你要跑的
就即便没有打到上规
你要走
这个角度是不对的
懂了吗
就是说他下来75
上去70
神经病
下来是这个角度对吧
上去是这个角度对吧
走不远的
明白了吧
那肯定是这个地方有什么事情
在A股里面经常会发生
比如说降因花税了
一般两天之后就回来
就是你看到这个地方
如果这个地方配合基本面消息面的刺激
有一些利好消息
导致这种非常陡的上涨出来的时候
你不要想到怎么去做多了
你就想到这个多
你又赶紧就出来了
懂了吗
赚到钱你就要溜了
不要去持仓的概念
这是一些经验的东西
就是说他跌的快
长的快他走不远
他跌的快他长的慢
他走的远
记住了不
因为有足够的时间去消化
你这个玩意
你怎么上面的马蜂窝
就跟捅了马蜂窝一样的
上面全套牢盘
你这么一根线解放了呗
大家就回落了
懂了吧
本来的你没这么快
人家还不一定要动
懂吗
比如说你看这个区域都套牢
你什么一根阳线顶上去顶到这个位置
你要不跑才怪呢
这种慢慢的来
他就什么
上面的人就望远欲穿了
一摸就一个又过去了
对吧
你要是一根线直接就从哪里来跌回去
他又会打回来
记住了没有
很快
基准线会长了吧
那跌破他的那根线开始
找到他最高点
到他的最高点一连线就可以了
你比如说这一波你就这么画
这个高点和这个高点一连
做多拿到哪里的到突破上轨就可以止盈了回了吧那么这种信号呢一个月大概会出现五个五个
有五个机会
这五个机会并不是在一个品种上面
而是全市场至少会有五个机会给你
超跌反弹
当然像去年这种情况
它没有
对吧
几乎没有这种信号来的
那你没办法
懂了吧
只有美元有
对吧
但是美元的反弹你看到也是很弱的
因为美元它是一个大的大品种
因为所有的东西跟它有关系
所以去年你想找到那种跌得很惨的
找不到
对吧找不到的呀去年
就极端的年份呢
像这种量化宽松很凶的
你几乎是找不到那种
就回你看包括原油包括铜
从去年三月份到现在一共才回踩几次
不是回踩就是一共你看包括铜来说啊
你看看到这个铜
一次
两次
三次
四次
一共就四次
从去年到现在一共一年了
一年就给了
铜在天图上就给了四个信号
对吧
但是这个四个信号你抓到了
你也是赚的
蛮爽的
懂了吗
比较容易抓
OK
好
我们再说一个情况
有些年份它是这么走的
我用另外一个例子给大家说
等一下啊
我们看原油
你说那这一波怎么办
看好啊
这波跌的够狠吧
大家觉得这波跌的狠不狠
你看原油啊
从140跌到40跌了100美金对吧
然后其实你仔细看一下中间给不给机会
也有机会
对吧
中间也有机会做
看一下
这一波单边的过程当中
实际上也有超跌反弹
仔细看一下
给了几次
一次
两次
三次
四次
五次
六次
七次
八次
第八次
分台了
对吗
就是一个品种跌
怎么说呢
它下跌总有极限的
除了像去年那个原油变成负值以外
基本上很少见到这种情况
就哪怕从最高点下来
最多跌99%
99.99%
除了这个去年原油以外
特殊情况
黑天鹅的事情
懂了没有
那么你这个地方要做的就是
你要准备好你的资金
能够经受其几次这种穿透
明白了吗
那么很简单
你就把历史上跌得最惨的一个品种的
跌得最惨的那个年份拿出来
把它作为你的亮度和宽
然后去重新计算你的仓位和配比
就可以了
明白了
打个一
这就是量化的一个概念
你把历史上跌得最惨的一个年份拿出来
然后你的资金能够涵盖这个回撤
然后再去想办法去抓什么
抓反弹就可以了
那总共要涨回来的呀
对不对
总共要反弹的呀
涨多少
我之前跟大家说过数学的东西
对不对
你看啊
10块钱的东西跌到1块钱跌到多少
90%对吧
10块钱跌到1块钱
是不是跌90%
1块钱涨到2块钱涨多少
100%
对不对
一块钱涨到十块钱涨幅是多少
原理懂了没
那就一百块钱的价格
跌到一块钱
百分之九十
一块到两块就翻倍了
两块到四块再翻倍
四块到八块再翻倍
能够听懂的打个九
所以为什么
你抓超级反弹进场之后
你就要去设保本
因为你不确定
我这个地方能不能给到
对不对
有时候保本就没有这大你止损的
懂了吧
你进去之后
你就拿到保本点
然后你就等上线到不到
上线到了我就跑
上线不到
打我保本我就出来
给你抓到一次就够了
懂了吧
当然你说我这个区域
这个区域是我做顺势策略不好吗
可以啊
我说过不能做了吗你也可以做顺势对不对你也可以做顺势懂吗但是今天我没有讲怎么去做空
因为做空的这个参数不是21
记住了吗
下面是21
但是做空的上限
位置参数是不一样的
你跑出来的结果是不一样的
懂了吧
就上面这根白线的参数
不是21天
今天我不教你们怎么去做空
但是我估计你们大部分人都很喜欢做空
因为做空来钱快
对吧
来钱是快的
我还是那句话
做多才能帮你赚到大钱
你之所以觉得这个理论比较荒谬
是因为你没有赚过多头的钱
所以你没感觉不到
懂了吧
你就想象吧
一个股票从十块钱掉到一块钱
你就一块钱买进去
涨到五块钱
这种感觉
你自己想一想
和一个人从10块钱
低到1块钱
他一直在持仓
然后价格从1块钱
再涨到5块钱
他的成本价在10块钱的感觉
能一样吗
所以我说你有做过股票的概念
就是说操纵过上亿资金
在股票里面
怎么说呢
就是你做过项目的人
你该理解我在讲的东西
下跌的时候不是我想拿货就能拿得到的
那你说我这几十万
那你什么买啊
闭着眼睛就可以成交了
你资金到了之后你买不到东西
头疼
明白了吧
所以你们要有机构的思维
懂了
机构在下跌的时候
他也想拿到货
拿不到啊
散户不搁
他想说他要控盘吗
他没有筹码呀
他总不能拿枪逼着大股东
你又把这筹码给我
不可能
因为超过5%就要举牌了
对吧
那怎么办
那只能得散户卖呀
想办法呀
往往到末端的时候
你看
每个航天到末端的时候
都会急加速一波
一般就跌个8到10天
跌完了
跌完之后极度锁了
然后突然之间
砰放量起来
然后再锁了
然后再放量
是不是都是这样的
除非这个品种就没了
以后就没有消失了那股票的话退市了那有可能归零了一文不值了这商品不一样明白了吧那么这个策略跟大家说一下
在商品上的效果更好
为什么
对于货币来说
你货币不可能像什么
铜啊像油啊跌80%
很难
你说美元这个朋友跌80%见鬼了
欧元这个朋友跌80%
这很难实现的
因为全球没有任何一个央行
希望自己的货币跌成这个样子
而且货币实话实说
它的实际涨跌幅是很有限的
你们之所以觉得货币好玩
是因为它叫了杠杆上去
懂我意思吗
人觉得货币好玩
是因为叫了几百倍杠杆上去的
懂不懂
你真的去做银行的那个结会购会
没有杠杆你玩玩看你就知道了
没意思的
他可能一年就波动5%左右
3%左右对不对
我实话实说啊
你会觉得好玩是因为人家免息贷款给你去加杠杆
那么他贷款的给你的目的是什么
你要去想这个事情
但是商品的波动肯定会超过什么货币汇率的波动
明白了吗
懂不过
而且恕我直言啊
我们玩的货币
我们玩的这个
负尔瑞克斯市场
实际上跟银行见的不是一回事
我们这个叫暗金交易
提手旁那个暗
对吧
暗金
就是保证金
动则500倍
动则1000倍
波动一共就3%一年
那加了杠杆上去就可能500%
300%
实际上就没
其实你仔细看就没那么多吗
那么额外多出来这些杠杆
实际上对于你的风险
就是无限放大了
懂了没有
但是商品不一样
因为商品它有波动
它的波动可能一年是50%的波动
那么再加上杠杆的话
它的边界效应要高于什么
货币
高于外汇
懂了
当然很多人说我讲的不对啊
实际上你们自己想想这件事
对吧你看人民币掉的惨吗而不是甚至甚至甚到快了其实也没甚少你自己去看吧,从去年3月份到现在人民币升值升了多少钱你自己说按照绝对百分比算的话
懂吧?那么现在问题就来了
以后
现在还有很多外汇平台啊,动则上百倍的,你看FCA
澳大利亚
香港
现在多几倍了
你看越规范的
越严格的监管
杠杆就越低
对吧
监管越偏的
什么岛国啊
什么群岛的啊
什么哪里那边杠杆越高
你有没有注意到这个事情
这个现象现在在整个福瑞克市场里面很普遍了
为什么
逃避监管
如果我现在按照FCA的监管
老子赚不到钱
对平台上来说
同意的话打个一
你就让我给30倍
我赚西北风啊
我还不够我租罗德钱呢
对不对
我人工工资我不要怕
我推广的钱我还是上的
我一个月打给那个
门户网站的
广告费都要几十万的
对不对
你就给我30倍
我赚鬼钱啊
而且就是赚的也很慢吧
对不对
更不要说很多都是对冲的
懂了吧
所以他们就逃避监管
很简单的道理
在什么群岛上面
在什么
可能连我们一个省都没有这么大的国家
对吧
法外之地
是吧
说实话压根就没监管
但是他有批文
就拿了个批文出来
你看我们这
然后你去核实的时候
全英文你也看不懂
就算你客人懂得吗
也是那种什么擦边球的
对吧
比如说他们不包含保证金交易
但是包含什么
外汇结会啊购会啊
这种许可是有的
但是他没有说
能够允许你展开
这个保证金交易
或者MM的对吧
都是党擦边球的嘛
那么不出事就不出事
出事了门
你自己去想这个事情
对吧
我不是跟大家以前聊过这个事情
说实话
我是不鼓励大家去做这个
高保证金的东西
你想一个平台给你开2000
被你疯了
这个人什么实力啊
就是说你用一块钱
他寄给你九千块钱
然后让你去做生意
那他给有多少钱
他是持三价吗
是不是
你们静下心来好好思考一下这些问题
不光是从台面上去分析考虑
还是从行业上去考虑
懂了没有
有人说我们这个市场一天一兆
一兆的流动性
那跟我们做的不一样
他说的这个一兆是全球贸易上面用到的
外汇交易量
懂了吗
实话实说
我这边数据统计就是
我们现在从亚太地区能够出去的单子
也就四千万张而已
一年
懂了吧
四千万张
这4000万张不是MT4 MT5
就是所有加起来都是
比如说直通的这个纽交所
轮交所就全球科大交易所的这些单子
加上MT4
加上这个比如说护轮通
中国的这些护轮通
一年也就4000万
早几年是7000万张
到今年为止已经减了一半了
懂了吧
就能够对出去的就这么多
还有很多没有对出去的
就没有直通到你懂的啊
就压根就没出国
对吧
就在内循环
懂了没有
就他连出境都没有出境
只是说
你转账到他国内的这个账户
然后他国内就对冲掉
他没有流入到国际市场
懂了吧
没有出去
那么没有出去这个钱
那么人家
行业
行业规则好一点的话
就是说你赚了我就给你
但我也不
我也不卡你出境
我也不怎么样
这个还比较好一点
碰到那种你牛逼
你比较牛逼
你一下子就赚几千万的
人家不给你出钱了
账户直接给你拉掉
你要是这逼得紧
他就换平台了
重新换一个名字
再去到什么地方
花个几千美金
几万美金搞一个牌照
从头开始
换个名字了
同样一帮人
懂了吧
换个外汇的牌子就可以了
懂了没有
而且我跟你们说句实话
比如说你说以家政为例
当然我们就不具体点名啊比如说A公司国际大牌没问题A公司啊全球最大的这个美经济商
对吧
上市公司等等等等
没问题啊
在他们的国家是
Number One
监管好
质地好
但是记住
到了大中华地区
大中华的地区的经营管理
跟那边是
不是一拨人
你能懂我意思吗
从监管到审核到合规
到其他地方
跟那个A公司的
就在国内的公司不是一回事情
在中国的那个
在大中华地区的是另外一拨人在运作
能听懂的打个二
然后呢
他在大中华地区
他就发分包
也不是要分包了
就是说四级代理
他四级不展开具体业务
他只是负责推广扶持
扶持次级代理
然后代理再代理
代理再代理
然后推广砸下去烧
第三方介入再烧钱
那个
只负责一件事情就可以了
就资金渠道
出入金的通道
还要提供一些这个
法务维权的方面的这些知识
以及你的这个场所的这个
经费他们会给
具体下面子代理自己去开展就可以
是这样一个运作方式
其实我就把这个内幕给你们讲一讲
那么子代理就会做很多出轨的事情
比如说同一个平台
那两个客户
电查佣金是不一样的
懂了吧
可以调佣金
可以调手续费
手续费也是可以调的
懂吗
可以调佣
可以调手续费都可以
还要返佣
懂了没有
对
那么现在说实话都不用交保证金
以前还要交
现在不用交的
那么子代里就会出现很多
出轨的事情对吧
当然服务器是一个服务器
对了大中华地区还要负责服务器的架设问题
其他就没什么了
就是每个月社会推广对不对拿点资源你们下面自己去看业务对吧一般业务
一般这种公司
怎么弄的
门口挂一个教育机构的牌子
某某什么学画画的
美容医疗的
或者是其他什么机构
他肯定不会挂这个牌子上去
或者某某信息科技公司
里面弄一些这个直播的电脑
直播的电脑知道吧
就是有镜头的
好几个房间隔开
别人来查的时候
说你们在干嘛的
我们在抖音带货的
懂了吧
就查到了过去之后
你看人家在带货吗
懂了没有
我们开抖音的
就是挂的羊头卖狗肉
就是能够在国内
现在还在滞留在国内的这些
做业务的
那么基本上就是这个套路
把大部分人都已经出去了
就国内就不呆了
懂了吗
呆不了啊
这个警察说一抓就抓到了
对不对
一冲楼
你们在干嘛他
别动啊
双手抱头
蹲下来
电脑的这个电源线给我拔掉
把机箱给我拆下来
一个人拿这个机箱
搭了个头套
坐电梯
一个一个下
然后门口一辆公安的大巴就等着你
你就上去
手机啊
随身财务全部放在一个小的密封袋里面
好
给你编个号
你是几号
上车就行了
然后拉到里面干嘛
问你啊
你们家里面干什么事情呢
你做什么动作
不是你干什么工作的
然后你说我我就打个电话的客服
一般都放了
对吧
那么组长呢
别走
就是你啊
组长是你吧
好
经理经理在不在
就你告诉我谁是经理啊
一摸摸出来了
对吧
你们老板呢
联系方式呢
一条线录上去
也就录到什么
次级代理结束了
懂了没有
录到次级代理就结束
这条线就结束了
再想往上查就很难了
那是大中华地区了
再查他不在境内
他在国外去了
服务器都掉到国外的
懂了吗
很难查
而且你查流水的话也是很多太空账户很难查而且都是第三方的还有一些是走USTD的对吧那更差不到了但是警察说不管
他一般来搞你
他肯定知道你这边有钱
没钱他一般也不会来搞
是吧人家也要那个的
也要看你
对吧你这个哥们还有点钱
那来请你喝茶
你把钱吐出来就行了
对吧本来
我可以告你诈骗的
那你要是清退退赔的多一点
那我给你搞个非法经营
对吧
就律师有关系的情况下面
而且你愿意积极退赔的情况下面
可以把从诈骗定到什么
非法经营
那关个三五年
或者说判三缓三这种
都懂了吧
好就可以了
但是人家钱也赚够了
好吧
就是这一类的这个目前的这种情况
当然这个钱到底会不会推到投资者手里呢
就不得而知了
好吧
据我所知去年我比特币的反正都上交国库了
对吧
后面我就省电话
你懂的啊
方道话打个六
反正比特币这个东西肯定上交国库的啊
因为首先没办法记名
对啊
你说你转账
你这把你都变成USTD了
你怎么查
既然查不到那就充公
对不对
好
那么今天就把这个系统分享给大家
好吧
然后呢
也不要问我什么行庭的事情了
讲明白就行了
好吗
你现在要做的话很简单
两个方式
你按照今天的这个系统做
你今天是下不了仓的
对吧
没办法下仓
那么你就等两个点
要么你就等这个下一次的
然后你划线
二种情况是
这个地方等不到了
就等它上去
等这个黄线往上走
对不对
价格再往上
对吧
回答的时候
找机会
反正都是有一个动作
就是先先往下再往上
这个动作你要
就是你要有这个
找到这个原理
明白了吗
然后
天图讲完了
周线图
周线图的机会更少
现在给大家看一下
以黄金为例
你要在周线图上等一个信号
等很长时间
我们来看一下
离现在最近的一次在哪里
在这
那打个1
这个位置
对吧
这个地方
那么我们按照这个原因
它是不是跌跌穿了
这个地方的21天地点
你画个线
明白了吧
再往前找
找不到了
那就这里还有一次
对吧
你看数一下
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
8到10之间
没有骗你对吧
然后你画个线
再往前就是这
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
画个线
你可以这么画
有吧
你看啊
一次是在哪里啊
这里给了你一次机会
对吧
还有这给了一波
还有现在
周线上可能一年都看不到一次
那今年比较好
今年第一年就来了
你看这个点是16年的
这个点是什么
18年的
对吧
这个点的话是去年的
11月份的
现在3月份给了
那么你按照现在
今天将你周线上应该怎么去画呢
明白了
打个1
那么现在你就干一件事情了周先生你干嘛进场了之后保本一挂就上找上去你进去了比如说你这个点进
你也不是进的
你就过两天进去了
保本损一挂
好
要么打我保本
要么打到上轨
你再出来
就摸到上轨就算了
以后你就可以走了
明白了没有
当然这个上轨
目前看有可能会往下
再往下来一点
可能实际的你触及到的这个点位
还不是现在这个位置
它可能过两天再往下来一点
到这
或者再近一点
反正你看它时间
对不对
那么这里满足几个条件
从这个波段往前数是几根线
你去数一下
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
我前面讲正态分布的时候
大家都听到了
对吧
8到10
左右
OK
那么现在就是一个机会
我本来已经跟你说了
也是这个方法
你可以自己去复盘
懂了没有
你把以前的行情都拉出来看一下
能够做中性的人都不是一般人
听得懂没
能周线吃到
对吧
我愿意称为你是什么
你误了
懂了没有
你真的误了
那你误不到呢
你只能在15分钟小多期在这边
懂了没有
也不是说家里有矿吧
那就你拿这一波算吧
这一波从1780到1750好了
对不对
那这一波这一波很爽
对吧
你自己往前复盘看一下
你看这边
你看这是第一次对吧
破看到了没有
你是首线呢
这边画吧
你看这边触及过一次了吧
画线你自己就画
但是在这一波行情当中
对不起
他只有08年才给的机会
除此以外一个机会都没给你在周星图上来看看到了没有给他没没有吧没有吧只有这一段有那么整整从2000年
到2010年
这10年当中
只给了08年这一次机会
所以我说
能够赚大钱的人
他都不是一般人
懂吗
他的方法肯定跟别人不一样
他就别人理解不了他的
懂了没有
你人家看到这个地方
那么不行
这个地方破位
我们那麽做空去
对吧
这明显见顶了
还要跌的
那你懂原理的人就不一样
你看
对不对
然后什么
你再看月线图
月线图就不是以月
就是你用月线图做
就不是以月来做这个什么
区分了
他肯定是上年就好几年的事情
年纪的就你持长时间
懂了吧
至少半年半年一年以上的这种情况
就拿了很长时间来呀
懂了没有
你看这里
就这个就这个地方给过两次
没了对吧
你后面那么没有啊
那么你看人家是在
这又有机会了看到了没有
这帮人又有机会了吧
你看
从这买进去不动了呀
对吧
不动了吧
是不是啊
拿着
说实话
我现在还做不了月薪级别的
没有办法
这个
以我目前的这个状态
我也拿不住
这个你谁拿到住
你说谁谁拿到住
对吧
那是疯子啊
那肯定是家里不愁吃不愁穿的人
对吧
没有什么欲望的人可以的
就但凡有点欲望的
这种行情都拿不住的
我也拿不住
实话实说
懂了没有
什么一报报十年
那肯定很难
你想人生有几个十年
再过二十年我就退休了
还拿这种行情吧
对吧
所以呢我说了到周
到周线级别已经算到顶了
要做这个
你你首先你给活
你最少能活一百多岁吧
对吧
你自己算嘛
对不对
你说你前十年都一直在亏钱后十年你就是掌握了技巧开始什么走上巅峰了对不对那你还有多少个寿命你要想这个事所以这个级别我做不了的
懂得没有
我也做不了
但是呢
原理在这里
所以如果你现在二十出头
你还有机会
那得到一波史诗级的月线级别的机会
那恭喜你
比如说
离现在不远吗
2015年的时候
这
现在是2021年
那么这个六年时间你
成功了
哪怕你现在的回调
对你来说
你就少赚一点
你还是赚的
对不对
但是有个问题
为什么我说我这个级别
我拿不住的原理是
还有一个问题
就是平台的问题
十年这个平台还在不在啊
啊
对吧
你想你想这个事啊
这个平台还在不在了
而且你想你到时候你的出金
你要给你给不给你出
你要想这个事情
这又不是说这种正规的啊
你用我们国家规定的合法的这个交易所
你这玩意说死就死的嘛
对不对
当年的铁汇
我不要吃亏了吗
赚了钱出不来
出不了金的
对不对
我也经历过这种事情
所以你拿不住原因
其实有各种各样的原因了
所以到月限级别
我说实话
咱们是做不了的
不可能
太难了
我进去的目的
我要为了出金的
我又不是
要不要付小机的了
对不对
但是月限级别
什么时候可以做
我给你们讲清楚
对
你做实物黄金和ETF
就可以用月线图做
明白来打个六
保证金你不能拿这个做
你保证金拿这个做
你隔夜费你吃不消
第一个问题
第二个出金不给你出啊
对吧
你他妈进去一手
你滚这一波
滚到这你都不让你出金的
而且你出金出出来也有危险
为什么
超过现在银行转账
超过几万
超过七万八万就要被监管掉了
对不对
就你银行突然之间有很多流水进来
那肯定要查的
这叫不明收入什么东西
就是无法解释的这种收入合法收入
你解释不了对不对
你还要叫平台给你开盈利证明
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕